the most systemically racist thing in  America for black people is gun control  could you talk about that a little bit  more yeah you might not no if you don't  know gun control was the concept was  literally started hey we don't want  those blacks [ __ ]  we don't want those people to have the  means to defend themselves  don't let them have it right as we just  saw in New York state overturning those  oh you can't carry a gun on you that  literally had roots in the racist  practice of gun control so I'm not again  I'm not advocating for krasner or any of  these guys to say  hey you should be charging those guys  just for having a gun no I'm saying  there's a line the line is you use a  firearm to shoot someone we got it on  camera we have to prove that it's you  let's charge it right I'm here all day  for that yep but you're going around  running around oh he he had a gun on I  don't care